oh my god you grew up hey your dad told
me that you're thinking about coming up
here for college
it's exciting yeah maybe
you new to town I'm visiting my aunt I'm
Katie
sit
hey I get off in about ten minutes if
you want to I don't know go for a walk
or something okay you're in cool yeah
she is a writer you write a lot about
religion you really believe in like a
heaven and hell and all that I believe
in grace I believe in a complete meaning
somewhere you really think we're gonna
see my mom again
do you ever have sex sorry is that okay
yeah sure I do
really yeah when I'm with you distracted
think yeah Myranda what and I'm trying
to big it's been forever hasn't it
can't tell you a super I I don't want to
have sex with you what is that weird
so you were both married two men I was a
widow betty was married gonna burst so
you liked it and you didn't are you
asking if we liked it so it is not a
handicap to have one thing but not
another we are different shapes and ways
and our happiness is unique so what are
you into
[Music]
you